dude uh you guys have been really
[ __ ] me up with this fighting stuff
because i already i used to watch that's
good yeah
i used to watch this video all the time
of this dude named master wong
it was like wing chun and he does this
thing where he goes
wing chun vs boxing yeah and i thought
it was real
i thought it was real i got a cabinet i
used to i used to watch his videos like
all the time religiously i i got a
camera name i got a master wong
and he has this video where he's like
bring him up now hold on
you gotta understand that for whatever
reason it made us inroads in the
in the hood and a lot of the brothers
okay we're practicing wing chun now
a lot of the brothers hold on no we know
a lot of the
brothers who were practicing were very
very athletic and had a little boxing in
there
and under their belt as well so you
would see some wing chun guys
tournaments
kicking and punching like a [ __ ]
and they're like oh you must be a wing
chun guy meanwhile the guy was built
like
like he belonged in the nfl and you'd
see him at taekwondo tournaments and
they'd come in and just
[ __ ] up dudes because they were just now
you got a question you got to watch this
you got to watch the video though
and why why i thought it was real yeah
sure no i didn't
since you guys are a little young to
remember boxing versus wings in the 80s
that was a thing
there was there were all those and all
those martial arts best of the best
yeah all that sport so so a lot of
people a lot of the
there's there's go down now that's
scroll down scroll down the third one
change how the guy with the grade no no
yes that one now give yourself to load
the tabs the tabs are loading them
okay watch that video watch
watch him though that's a that's a legit
block watch
you see you'll see why i thought it was
real this one some of these guys are
fighters just because you're wing chun
doesn't mean you haven't punched people
in the face and i thought this would
listen to this that's him there uh yeah
but watch but
that guy's [ __ ] serious you can see
how i thought it was real look at his
intensity the thing
what do you mean by that uh well i mean
oh he's in english
where are they
then you'll definitely need a pair of
gloves one just test that see what you
mean
so i guarantee this guy's head on the
train so this is real yeah but i
guarantee he's had other training he
looks sure i can already tell
he's boxed him see how he stopped that
boxer
that's [ __ ] huge he's not really
trying to hit him that's not real
he's not really trying to come here
straight away
yeah that's all [ __ ] because let me
tell you something
listen you're not gonna be able to hit a
punch like
but here's here's the thing about here's
the thing about me
i didn't read the comments i was just
like [ __ ] this video yeah i don't
need her
and i would i don't even really so then
i started reading the comments
and everybody was saying [ __ ] that you
guys would say yeah because we're not
stupid but i was like i'm sitting here
like yo
this [ __ ] dude i'm sure that's a
tough dude
dude i remember when i first saw the
video this is like a tutorial dude this
is just him [ __ ] around like showing
him
yeah yeah that's not going to i mean you
see does something that's not going to
block like they'll block
they do that muay thai [ __ ] where they
roll their shoulder you'll see that
sometimes you know
but but like i don't think this is gonna
yeah you know you watch guys in the ufc
hit each other like bang like now they
don't know that i've been watching ufc
like i
forced them to watch ufc 2 or 263. like
you watch you watch
you watch nate diaz take those shots
yeah he's rolling he's boxing so he's
rolling with those shots he gets hit but
he
he moves with the shots he keeps his
shoulder up so there's no way that can
stop a boxer it's not that it's not that
it's not that he couldn't block a couple
shots maybe like he's got his elbows up
in his pocket
right now he's not taking a leon edwards
jab and going yeah
right yeah there's just no way that
could happen no
listen when i first started maybe he's
like flingling his arms
it's like this like if i may it's like i
don't think fighting
stops at those two punches right like
the guy goes pop up and then leonardo
gets blocked and he he readjusts yeah
it's like so with with
muay thai so i back kick you can do a
taekwondo backhand it's actually
something that people you can catch
people with yeah a couple times
what happens is then they readjust and
they go i see what you're doing
and they take that away but the fight
keeps going there it's it's not it's not
it doesn't stop there it's like that
yeah you know what i mean
you don't go ah it's just different and
there's a weird
analogy but this guy was talking about
how he showed this kind of a disturbing
thing a guy had a girl on the ground
with a gun and he was beating her it's a
real video yeah and the cops
what'd she do who knows he dragged her
out he was uh he was
his shirt oh it was it was like real so
the cops saw he had a gun so they shot
him and you watch it it goes
eleven times and he's doing this nine
millimeters
like that now that he's just a superhero
he's still got the clothes got the gun
that's 11. that's 11 shots oh he's back
and he's walking he's still walking
toward them
he's still walking towards that girl yep
and now
and now is this bane right and they
shoot him two more times so what the guy
said
is he goes that's 20 seconds that's not
that uncommon
you there are people who are so jacked
up on stuff adrenaline
that's what i'm saying and when you if
you're not hitting spinal cord or you're
not hitting and you're hitting vital
organs
they can stay alive and then when they
hit the ground sometimes your blood
pressure goes up
so you still can get off rounds so cops
people get shot all the time
it's not like the movies where you go
boom and the guy's dead you can shoot
dudes three times
with a nine millimeter this guy was nine
you said i'm sorry you shot him nine
times he shot him i thought it was
eleven times
[ __ ] yeah but if that's believe it or
not
a lot of guys can get shot back and they
and they get off three rounds and they
kill you too
that's why that's why it's that's why i
always aim for the face always aim for
the face
but they tell you to aim for center mass
because if you aim for the head there's
so much going on
you're going to miss and then you're
responsible for that bullet your
responsibility
you got it so body shot so you know when
people were like i don't get why i just
don't shoot them in the leg it's like
you know how hard to shoot somebody in
the middle you ain't gonna stop him you
shouldn't like he doesn't feel it
sometimes
and he keeps shooting at you because
when his adrenaline is going these guys
get
it was the guy who was walking towards
another video guy walking toward him and
he's crazy he's hitting him
and the cop shoots him in the chest bang
bang bang bang and he keeps coming
and because that's a superhero you have
20 you have 20 seconds that's why when a
guy has a knife and he's 20 feet away
it's so dangerous now i saw i saw a guy
on world star
uh the cops were like hey you know like
hands out of your pock's head and he
just
took his gun out and shoots the cop
right in the chest damn
and then they shoot him once and he
screamed like a little girl
yeah he was straight oh they only shot
him once yeah it just depends
right in the stomach though they say
it's the worst place to get shot there's
so much [ __ ] going on your stomach gets
shot in the stomach that's where [ __ ]
comes from
a lot of problems a lot of problems a
lot of issues you know they say it's the
one spot you don't want your head is the
tummy yeah
now now what's what's worse uh
a rifle or a pistol pistol what do you
think
pistol okay how come i only said that
because you asked this question
i'm just kidding that's because it's
closer range usually when you're firing
a pistol no
because of hollow points because of how
far right
by far like if you get shot with like a
like a uh
ar-15 i thought it was like a tree it's
just the speed of the bullet goes
it's the spirit throwing us a curve i
know that's what i thought
but of course they yeah it's a bigger
bullet you always say the ar
brian what the [ __ ] this is uh this is
an arab
15. why do you have a bullet underneath
yeah it's an empty one okay i got it
like when i worked at the gun store they
gave me
oh by the way guys you shot one right
you remind me of chad
could they be any louder that's why is
that [ __ ] up you're like chatterbait
shutterbug i'm gonna shoot myself in the
gym but you don't
shut yourself in the leg oh
they're so loud you need ar-15s yeah you
can't have just little ear you need
[ __ ] hands even then it's intense
why do i want to do that because you can
like that's like a little dull down
you can feel how like a full sharp one
being shot into you can feel that
feeling
it's the energy displacement yeah when
it hits you it like creates a cavity
like that
it gets scary so needless to say i
should stop watching master wong videos
i would once you watch some real [ __ ] i
mean i know
well i don't i didn't i didn't realize
it until i started watching like
the fights like i did this weekend with
you and then i was like man
when i think about it i was like i
wonder if that guy could keep up with
these
answers now because i was like i saw him
you know destroy that boxer you know
with the clean uh
he's not a boxer but you but you watch
it for entertainment
that's what it is yeah but watch it you
have to ask yourself is
you really have to ask this question you
also thought uh
could beat francis how many fights how
many fights have they been in like how
many
times have they been in the ring and
competing yeah yeah i guess yeah you
know against guys the thing about the
ufc is
you're fighting dudes who are hiding
kickboxers boxers wrestling
you know what i'm saying that edward's
got he's a kickboxer right
that's his background but he's good at
everything oh but he's good at it okay
there no
everybody in the uc is getting
everything everything
interesting together they know
everything it's very interesting but i
think what i love watching is you watch
this yeah and what i love about
watching like izzy versus someone like
victoria or whatever
what i love about it is yeah well well
the reason is he is such a champ is
because he solves the problem in front
of him
and with all due respect to victoria's
toughest [ __ ] what i what i
saw was a limited game plan in
comparison to somebody who just had
the tools yeah you can't
yeah that's how his hands are down he's
going cool and oh yeah dude
that [ __ ] was crazy or is that what they
call that uh yeah
but that's what's what i love about that
kind of fighting is because izzy knows
all those patterns and he figures your
patterns out and you can't figure out
his stuff because his
is he has a rolodex i'll get killed for
this
oh god please i'm going to get killed
and you know so already bother me the
baggy neck on your shirt would go
back i know look at the sleeves too you
didn't wash it huh
no i washed it it's just he just didn't
iron it it's the
it's the style and the waves
[Laughter]
all right go before you say so this can
piss me off with go
you're gonna get killed for what rafael
cadero is a
a master coach and he's great the one
thing i was surprised at
was that in the corner he didn't seem to
be giving vittori
any kind of adjustments he was just
telling him to get there first maybe
that's what he's working with though
you know what i'm saying like maybe that
like i like how that light bulb has to
offer and he's like that's what i
that's what people want to criticize the
coaches but he knows him better than
anybody out there so
maybe he's like oh this like dude you
got to pin him down and
lay in the right hand otherwise it's
also fair to say that his team may not
be
may not know how to predict what izzy's
going to do because izzy's a [ __ ]
really high level
striker that's also possible yeah that's
what i just thought of well he's the
highest level
he's the highest level we have to offer
in this yeah so sometimes you have a
fighter who doesn't have those
but think about it you don't have the
tools so you're like what do you want to
tell him
something that he doesn't do like
something that he doesn't do yeah i'm
hey let's just step to the left and yeah
uh
that's not my that's not what i do yeah
because then that would have got him
[ __ ] up possibly
no it's just not his thing oh it's just
on his thing it's not a thing yeah might
as well tell him do a backflip you can't
do a backflip
hey you drive backflip i've never done
that yeah training i know but do it live
against the best in the world
true yeah okay i'll try it now yeah yeah
you get knocked out yeah
that's what i think yeah that's what i
think what did you think of nate and
leon
i loved it i loved that nate and kind of
rallied in the end
nate last 30 seconds durable he's just
so durable
and uh he's just a little disappointed
in leon
i thought leon was gonna because he's
that new blood i mean he pitched a
shutout
stuff for the last 30 seconds but he
didn't it's not like he didn't show
up he just couldn't get rid of him yeah
part of it was also maybe
you know it's it's all experience
fighting a veteran that's a lot of
energy leon's super experience
he's experienced but you know that's
sometimes that can [ __ ] with you a
little bit when you got the whole
crowd going nate and they can you know
but i thought he did a great job
well you said his last loss was to us
guzman yeah
here five six years ago oh [ __ ] yeah
he's he's a high level [ __ ] man
but nate nate's just
you know so much fun so game but yeah
i i feel bad for leon because the
narrative is just it's all about nate
now
yeah not leon yeah i think he knew that
right i think he knew that
nate i mean no he didn't want that but
nate's going in as an underdog so
you're going to know that the crowd is
going to be for oh no he knew that but i
think
he thought he'd beat him and then you
know the narrator would be about him but
right even though he was the underdog oh
big time the plus 500 yeah
which right i mean you saw how the fight
was yeah they only landed one right hand
the entire fight
yeah another high-level kickboxer like
high-level guy you know an athletic and
you know the whole deal he's so
entertaining to watch nate
i feel like just because he the beating
he can take on like he's he's a showman
i feel like he's
old school yeah that's how i look at it
i look at boxing and jiu jitsu old
school
he fights like he's on the streets of uh
stockton it's kind of historical the way
he just walks around kind of
like he kept turning his back to [ __ ]
with leon i i loved it it made me
yeah it's only cute if you're winning
yeah i agree but i mean like
he loses so he's he's he's lost seven
out of eight rounds his last fight
he got absolutely destroyed by mazda i
had two of those rounds ten eight
yeah and so he's lost every single round
except for that last right hand
uh yeah he's definitely past his prime
fighting-wise i feel like i'll always
pay to watch him fight
but uh to me the the ant takes like you
got you gotta you gotta be winning
yeah i i agree with you but it's in the
moment it's fun too like it's fun
we don't see it no one really does it
yeah i i does brother do the same [ __ ]
too i love
nick oh he's bro yeah i love nick
monster it was my favorite fighter are
you a fan
are you a fan chin of them other than
the diaz brothers of course yeah i don't
know anyone who doesn't really yeah
how do you not like i don't know why i'm
a fan i'm just like every time i watch
like if they're on tv yeah they're
they're just interesting to watch
like art yeah they're interesting to
watch yeah they're fun to watch
exactly and just great they seem real
too like super travel man yeah
yeah yeah no i'm a fan they beat the
game you know yeah they did they beat
they've i just worry about the amount of
just the head trauma that they do oh but
that's yeah you should
yeah yeah cause they they they did a lot
of boxing
out of in in
and i you know that those guys that's
not you're not just moving around you're
getting
[ __ ] cracked one of the best ever
andre
nate's also been in the ufc for what 10
years now i think more than that more
like well he
the ufc i think is he's been a mixed
martial arts for 17 years
yeah but i thought the year he was in wc
and ufc yeah
then one ultimate fighter i think that
you his ufc i could be wrong the ufc
debut i
think was around 2007 or maybe that was
his first loss or something uh
because i was looking at his stats over
the weekend he fought
the ultimate fighter finale 2007. wow
wc was in 2007. yeah think about 2004
he started fighting well his first fight
was in the wc he's been fighting since
2004 for
jesus and how old is he and he's only
he's only been finished once i see he's
38
30 36 36 he's the he those
brothers are so durable it's crazy and
he's i mean
nick's never been nick got hit by
paul daley is that is it paul daley well
daley gave him a left hook and he went
down on his head
on his hands and knees and then came
back and knocked paul daley out with a
left hook
it's like when you're fighting a guy
like paul daley you're supposed to do
the other stuff you're not supposed to
try to match their he's like nah i'm
gonna i'm gonna match you punch for
punch
they're crazy man they're just like such
outliers they're they're outlines
they're just outliers of
crazy cardio they do a lot of um
triathlons and i think nick oh they do i
think nate was talking about how they
used to train because they didn't have
any money
and they'd get a burrito after training
there was like you know it's just real
hunger man
how they have each other's back which
one's the older one
one on the left oh okay that's nick diaz
that was my favorite
time show your hall of famer [ __ ]
wait is he retired
no he's supposed to fight this year oh
god who is he gonna fight he's been off
for a long time
we have no clue who's going to fight but
dana said they're going to fight we have
no clue who
there's also i think that's just because
nick does give him a title shot
yeah how i'm fighting that you want to
pave to watch nick
is he kidding me oh yeah how great with
the antics being the build up and [ __ ]
what else we gonna do whitaker again
no notice like nobody complains nate
fought leon yeah
no business fight ladies coming off a
loss fight number three guy in the world
on
nine fight win streak nope nobody
complained we're like hell yeah that's
cool
anybody else you'd be [ __ ] furious
the ds brother's right yeah and the
fighters would probably be like cool
usually fires be like that that should
be my smart whatever if it's nick or
nate they're going to go for it their
fan base
crazy that would be funny rabid fanbase
that'd be so funny dude i'll tell you
where we were
uh oklahoma now you told me it was a
little hot
little city i've ever been to first of
all first of all i got a little i just
want to just give you a text that
brandon sent me this morning
first thing i get i'll show them the
dick pic no first thing i get when i
wake up
i just get this hey brennan can you
bench 415 i don't know let's see you
stupid [ __ ]
i hate to get a video of him doing 415.
you pop that up rather easily
take a look at him i could do did you
post it i didn't post it right
but look it out watch his chin watch
this watch how easy this is
like because i did 405 two weeks ago
for two pretty easy and then today i was
like i feel pretty strong felt so weak
in okc working out oh
these humidity yeah oh okc is my crypt
tonight when comes look at this right i
was so weak
by the way i'm going to be in albany
this weekend come see me
friday saturday me and duff david leave
thursday or friday
i leave thursday for new york city me
and dove are going to drive up to albany
how long of a drive is that oh that's a
beast it's a beast
yeah nice drive you know yep
you'll get to do it look at all the
fellas man i love it
we had so much fun man i look real
african in that part justin
watch sheesh so so i did four or five
two weeks ago for two and i was like
this
i've never do and i've never done 405
before so i did for two i'm like that's
pretty easy
so today i was like oh then i did four
or five today i was like that's pretty
easy
and then you know mark yeah yeah yeah
you did good really mark's like uh maybe
let's not go much heavier i'm like i
want to put on like 15.
i like mark that he's doing that i like
mark's great he's really good about that
i like mark that he's wearing blue to
bring out his blue eyes too i like that
too
hit it jen blue is his color
all right here we go i think i think i'm
going to max out i think i think i'm
around 4 25 4 30. yeah
five i wanna go i was gonna say i was
gonna say you could i can't do the 425
you could probably do work up to it no
no because i'm gonna see that start
cutting weight too that's so much weight
watch this though look at how long his
arms are i'm sorry that looked very easy
yeah
yeah you're doing 425 right i'm thinking
4 30. i think 4 30
4 30. i don't think 4 30 is a bad oh you
don't i could try
it now oh yeah oh yeah i'll do it next
week
i think 450 is the goal agree
summer goal that's the start of the 50's
let's not do we've already done the
deadlift let's not go overboard
i will never do that again he did it
this weekend
i did five what did i do 525 and okay
for four
yes i'm like and then how is your back
it's just tight
yeah just tight yeah we don't need to do
that no i'll i'm still going to deadlift
i'm just not maximum stop thinking about
it yeah i'm stuck oh yeah i don't need
to do it yeah
i'm going to do that but even mark's
like let's not max out on yeah dude
you shut your hormones it was so hard to
work out in okc it's the humidity we
walked to the gym it was a mile and a
half away
everyone was dying oh we were done we
took our shirts off everyone
yeah we took our shirts up on the wall
too hot oklahoma
you know i've been all over dude i don't
know i've been all over here you're
talking about humidity oh my god
bro you know what's so funny they were
they were all totally focused they were
all telling me a week before
it was it was cold yeah and then the
[ __ ]
heat just came with the week we got
there now now daddy did a little rock
climbing
this weekend not for you too big and
i've heard spider-man i've rock
climbed before yeah yeah up up rock
anything you can do i can do it
with with
open when you fall you're on different
steroids yeah yeah
did you do like no real with like the
shoes yeah ropes you got really you're
doing like my boy
huddle when you like with the dude you
were you you were the nurse
well yeah but i'm roped in yeah you're
roped in yeah
if you fall you were doing this when you
fall
you're doing a rock in malibu yeah i was
in a real rock
but when you fall you do fall a little
bit right so when you're there and you
go
and you fall you get you get scrapped up
a little bit because you're gonna
there's a it's a rock yeah it's not fun
where's it hooked on to to keep i'm
definitely bigger than him you guys
that's what i'm saying i was like you're
bigger
how about how tall and how much is he
waging yeah bubba i i've been next i'm
bigger than him i've been next to him
and i don't believe that you're bigger i
don't you think he's six four i don't
know
i know he's a legitimate he's not 250
he's not he's not 255. i've been next to
him and i've taken him in
that's 2 14. yeah there's not a chance
but six four
i see him at that uh topanga cafe all
the time oh he must have lost weight how
tall is he he must have lost he's
six four six four yeah but he's not 250.
he's a big guy he's just
he's tall but he's not he's not like
he's not thick you know you may not have
the legs you do
i don't know i when i saw him when he
was doing conan
maybe he was doing some stuff but when
he did conan was when i first i bet he's
gotten above
i bet see i i would i would i would have
thought he was six four two thirty being
that lean
yeah let me put it this way when he's
aqua man yeah yeah
he's awkward up when he's on all the
sauce
is that him that's aquaman now when he
checks for it but
when he was when he was doing uh he's
fine
he's fine oh dude he's gorgeous have you
ever seen him in person i've never he's
here she's dude
i know he kicks it with a lot of some of
my favorite skaters he makes me look
like a [ __ ]
he seems like a cool dude he's so good
gorgeous that when i saw him he's doing
conan nobody knew who he was
we was at ashay and he was walking
backwards and i and everybody was
talking to stop being trapped
everybody was talking about him
everybody's going who is he
who are you like what do you do that you
look like this yeah
he had a t-shirt on and he was bigger
than everybody i went what do you do and
he goes
i'm playing conan in a movie and i go
well of course you of course you are
yeah you look more conan than the real
conan did you just suck them off on
i don't know i'm not gonna [ __ ] i
wasn't always about to give it to you i
remember it was a long time ago i was
drunk
oh because he likes that yeah oh okay
now that's your thing that's nice
no you know everybody stop god those
tits now you know how everybody stops
mark
because mark looks ridiculous oh yeah
yeah he's the same but he's really
famous
yeah yeah was was conan in his first
movie
he used to be watched before his
breakout was game of thrones
breakout was game of thrones when he's
yeah he started baywatch he was dead
broke in game of thrones
story while it was airing people like oh
dude you're the door rack from
game of thrones he's like cool and then
he had would walk back to his van and
sleep in his van well he was on a sci-fi
show for six years um
revlon five or what yeah something like
that stargate atlanta star gate oh
stargate yeah
but yeah you gonna make no money on
stargate no no no
the money goes bubba it just goes yeah
it goes
now he's in a bunch of [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
he's counting
he's straight up would you say he's cal
drogo you do whatever he wants now
who is that and aren't they doing uh
aren't they doing a whole series about
that uh cal drogo no they're doing one
um as a prequel to game of thrones where
they are focusing on the
uh targaryens boring the magic
what do you think
is he the hottest guy in hollywood uh to
me every girl wants to [ __ ] him
yes yeah absolutely so does every guy
including a straight guy
yeah i'll
still is they have kids really yeah and
you know he's part of think boy bike
club he's a specialized guy he rides
bikes like a [ __ ]
yes so zoe kravitz that's her stepdad
yes
wow yeah he's a legend man mm-hmm
good for him nice guy too i don't know
but my body
bodied up he i mean him i mean if you
want to book a big guy yeah dave
bautista
[Music]
older though yeah now that's his big
father that's
i think batista is one of those he's
really bigger than you
i just saw him he looked i mean these
guys i've seen all these guys too
they'll be
i feel like he's bigger than you you've
seen batista in person yeah he's he's
big see how much he weighs because i
don't know he has to be 217
284 289 he's huge man
he's big i used to have such a crush on
him when i was a kid watching wwe
batista yeah he was in that speedo yeah
i think it's because he's part filipino
i just like
something about filipinos i look at them
and i know exactly what i'm doing
i'm so attractive i don't believe i
think there he's 290 god you think he
did roy
listen i think there is 280 but
he's not 280 in hollywood now that's no
i think he's smaller now yeah
that's wwe you know did you watch the
army of the dead did i watch what army
of the dead
the movies oh that's internal no
hardcore hard pass
now is that all over here is that all
the gear all of it
is it is it's a zombie film huh yeah
it's a zombie i can't get into zombie
movies dude
it was probably the worst thing i've
ever seen i'm not gonna lie
once they took my boy chris dulane out
of it i went nope
i'm out there's a scene in there that
looks
like it's dizzy-ish have you seen it
it's kind of like colors and it just
stays that way forever
uh digitally removed and they put the
new character in and so they started
adding that like hazy effect
that ruined the movie entirely uh
stylistic choices yeah i heard you're
really bad yeah i heard it's really bad
it's not good you got bad reviews i just
don't like zombie movies
you don't like zombieland like [ __ ] no i
don't give a [ __ ] oh wait zombieland
zombies it's funny because that was fun
bill murray pops up yeah he pretends
he's a zombie
there's another one the second one's all
right i like the bill murray the bill
murray scene at the end of the second
one too i thought that was [ __ ] scary
oh it comes back
yeah it took an after like an after
credit thing oh
not really but yeah no there's a british
one i think it's shot
that one's funny so yeah i like the
funny zombie movies
like ones that are like oh so you've
seen a bunch of zombie movies i've seen
two you just named the two [ __ ] most
famous ones no they're not the most
famous ones
donna the dead is the most famous one
they've had another that was the
first uh walking dead the most famous
movies yeah probably you'll watch movies
that's terrible i got to start watching
movies again you look great
somehow what are you saying though thank
you what are you saying though you had a
question for me
do you watch a lot of movies no no no no
not
anymore uh no no i mean my girl watched
uh
like we're re-watching yellowstone rick
and morty
also the best show that's [ __ ] really
that's why i go to montana now once a
year
really obsessed with it really it's so
good
you never seen it it's not it's cut off
by the way
it's so good sorry that's french for
what it's so good
you'd love that you
yellowstone though why yeah uh i don't
know it's just really done well that
taylor sheridan wrote it he also did uh
he does a lot he does a lot of great
here i loved him i loved it man i didn't
see what he doesn't miss
kevin costner's so good in it and then i
got then the girl
on the right he she's [ __ ] amazing
just the story what about what about
your favorite character
that one guy i like that are you talking
about uh
yeah that guy rip rip i started calling
boston rip my girl's like please don't
call him rip
why he's he's uh he's the badass he's
like the he's the muscle
he's the muscle for their i'd like it oh
it's so good dude
it's my favorite show of all time it
takes place you in the western modern
day or what
yeah no it's not western i thought it
was no it's [ __ ] great
yeah the bath and rip on the far right
are the and they shoot it in montana
uh actually half in montana half in utah
wow oh i love it out there i love it out
there
in utah and montana both oh you talked
about montana
utah it's cool montana is a special
place i'm going in september
people live they say don't tell people
about it well just all the [ __ ] will
move up there yeah
montana is amazing man yeah it's so nice
i think john may recorded an album up
there in montana
mm-hmm it was montana have you done
stand-up
boise i've never done stand-up in
montana i'm trying to think the major
city
might uh they have a killing festival
out there you fly into billings
yeah i've been there we went there we we
hunted up there me and rogan uh
in the missouri breaks and that [ __ ] up
there oh
that's when you guys went camping get
yourself some bear up there
oh
how about crazy [ __ ] mark harley in
oklahoma we're like waiting for an uber
and says like 25 minutes
and he goes how far is it i go two miles
do you guys i'll meet you guys there
just
yeah racy is here flapping up again
after we just had that crab town yeah we
just had like the
eighteen paul versi was talking about
crap down there yeah we went there it's
good
yeah yeah you know my my friend dated i
think her name is amelia bloom
she's the uh number one mud
tough mudder yeah in the world she's a
woman who
she ran like like she beat all the men
you know i don't know
and he said that they would literally be
driving and they'd be just get out well
they'd be
you know 18 miles away or even
26 miles away from like you know home
the destination and she'd go i'm gonna
and be
like driving highway she goes i'm gonna
run and be like
what are you doing she's like i'm gonna
run back she's probably thinking this
[ __ ] small talk
just [ __ ] run and he'd see her for
dinner dude my adopted father he just
turned
50 and he's gonna do 50 miles he's a big
runner oh he's always going to say oh
he's a big big
oh my god he ran the [ __ ] grand
canyon and [ __ ]
never been my thing
you should do 55 miles for your 55th
birthday never do it dude do
60 miles swim 60 minutes yeah
i don't care about being here tough
mudder hey you're not [ __ ] i want you
to do it
who's still in great shape and you know
he's [ __ ] you know yeah
yeah but he's still got it
i'm gonna get old and i'll stay scrappy
yeah a state but you don't run you're
not you're not an old guy i'll be
scrappy old guy
that's what i'll do that's fine scrappy
old guy punch you in the [ __ ] old
scraps
or just am the guy yeah hang on to that
yeah you don't have to yeah like i don't
give a [ __ ] you go [ __ ]
you with your running [ __ ] you you know
who else you know also oklahoma cat and
stephen
you guys were there it's all steven
stevens yeah he looks
like a uh in between a biker and a
military veteran it looks like a vietnam
vet it's all right yeah yeah and you
guys too small to be a biker
yeah did he get up on stage or he just
no no just hanging out
you guys just went to oklahoma yeah
what'd you think of oklahoma
oklahoma surprisingly has better food
than i thought uh we got there
and there was nothing open the night we
got in
except for this like weird lounge and we
looked up it was called rnj's lounge all
the photos on instagram if you
go through their geo tag is like a bunch
of plus size like burlesque
girls plus size yeah and so like nipple
tassels
thongs and then one girl is like taking
the champagne
guts yeah one girl had champagne pouring
down her body another girl was taking a
shot off of the champagne going off of
her phone
yeah and it looked like a woman but the
food was good yeah that was the only
thing
yeah the big [ __ ] were not there
unfortunately
no they weren't i wish they were or
maybe we had just
pulled it up body parts
no i can't eat those strip clubs you
know i will try the wings of that when
we go
do atlanta at magic the strip club i
guess they're known for their wings
yeah i'll eat some wings but if you've
ever had somebody like time for the
whipped cream
no i don't know like chocolate like
oh i'm like god damn [ __ ] i get a
shower after this
this is a night i'm all sticky i'm not
gonna hassle this dumb
yeah i'm not into it either um don't
they do like a sushi thing where you
sushi off someone's body yeah again yeah
again raw
put on a [ __ ] table man i'll take it
on my porch this poor girl
what horrible decision did she make it's
not just girls doing dudes do it too
not a lot of guys do you're cheerleading
your friend told you yet listen
where we come from but we're not
ordering where we come from
i don't have that number off just just
some big
hairy day big armenian like yeah you
like that spicy dude
just a hairy armenian oh hey make sure
you get some of that wasabi down there
you wouldn't let you wouldn't let people
eat sushi over your body no
life's too good to do that i'm too busy
too awesome too busy gonna lie down
don't move too much gonna put some
it's gonna be a two-hour dinner mind if
we put a little soy sauce in your belly
though don't turn into a conversation
we had the funniest security guard in uh
oklahoma
all right i told him i said hey if i'm
ever at like kevin hart's level
i'm gonna bring you everywhere he he was
the greatest really oh you can barely
understand what he's saying
he talked like dude hey what are you
doing buddy what are you doing
you can't really understand what he's
saying that's them that's where you went
yeah that's what they wanted to go says
guts and tongues guts and tongs
no gutsu so this does what now good for
them it's a
lounge and a restaurant i guess they
have burlesque shows
every now and then i don't see too many
thickies on there
the top two ones yeah the top two the
main is i saw a monte cristo
great sandwich with raspberry jam it's a
deep-fried
hand sandwich i had a monte cristo
not yeah not too bad just okay it was
good food though cat
surprisingly good food i thought it was
gonna be like okay to shitty food but
they're burgers
it actually does look really good burger
is really good we have the worst tacos
i've ever had in my life
out there where'd you go i don't want to
ride them out okay but you had tacos
while you were that was
the worst talk i've ever had
he had a chicken tender on a taco it was
awful wow awful my cauliflower tacos
were amazing so
cauliflower are you uh vegan no no
randomly the place goes i'll do
cauliflower
what the [ __ ] dude some days you just
want some veggies
some days yeah and that's fine right
sure well the thing is
when sure when you have a cold and your
friends
come to your house with tonics and
everybody's got a point of view on on
what to do when you have a cold uh-huh
all these botanicals and stuff cause
daddy got a little head cold i had a
little kid called that
little that little snout was running
bump yeah a little snout it wasn't
that's
a little snout in the old facey pacey uh
this past weekend and kept tonight
because
i'm fine joseph sent me a video you on
the beach
yeah well my stupid [ __ ] hat i was
wearing a hat to keep
sun from my little cold cold face i know
i don't look great
and then they they attacked me joseph
grabbed me because i was making fun of
him and he grabbed me and he brought me
to the ground
and then he was arresting me like he was
you know yeah and then i tried to get up
and they were kicking me
sand in your face yeah and so i got
kicked around a little bit in the sand
bite the old man up on the right with
the cold and you're all having a cold
well i haven't called
who is it uh who is it ryan yeah i love
ryan the best
the [ __ ] best owns the best
restaurant in san jose yep an alf gracie
black belt so
you know got some stuff going on and
they're kids i couldn't get up
and they're fun and i'm an old guy and
they're kicking me around hell yeah
and i was like you stop it and they said
they gave me a real
shove around they gave me a shove around
and a little kick around in the sand and
i had sand in my balls i had to take a
shower and it was in my cracks
and the whole time i was holding on to
my keys and my my wallet
and i was like oh then i'm trying to get
up
you should've yelled what beach was this
santa monica santa monica santa monica
oh i saw the cleaning up the bombs
they're cleaning up the bomb i saw i saw
a video yeah
i saw a video of a swarm of cops just
taking off
because the old sheriff because because
the city council member was making a
speech
uh about the homeless and a woman who
was naked attacked her
tried to threaten her with him yep and
then the sheriff was like you know this
is nonsense
yeah he's like we got to
there's nowhere for them to chill
there's not enough water building
they're building a whole structure for
them like an encampment the palisades
no way yeah the [ __ ] out of here yes i
promise
the richest places in la they're going
to build it there you'll see
really yeah yeah parker
i just think that the rule should be
that you're not allowed to have a
[ __ ] tent on the street you're not
allowed to have an encampment what you
do is you go to
state-run facilities and what happened
was the word got out you could live on
the beach for free they all came
yeah not good you see there was a mass
shooting in uh
austin right where i do that club oh
[ __ ] right there right on sixth street
it's
the when i say this you know when you
see movies then they show you alleys
like you know a guy like i guess i'll go
down this alley yeah it's like a rough
alley yeah
dude that alley behind the vulcan
theater right to the right of it
is the ghettoest alley i know exactly i
know
exactly what you're talking about we saw
some girl in like a mini skirt taking a
[ __ ] bird i was like no
no no no oh yeah yeah i know exactly
what you're talking about and i was
there that's where the shooting was
nothing good happens in that alley in
that area at
after 12 a.m get the [ __ ] out of there
if you're
hanging around with people that are torn
out of the floor i wouldn't be
comfortable down there it is not but
especially at night is that everybody's
pouring out bars
and dudes they're not getting laid they
want to fight [ __ ] happen
oh look at juvenile suspect what a
surprise i just started open firing
there was some uh like biker convention
going on though
yeah a juvenile yeah damn a 25 year old
die from it fox oh someone did die
our boy paul versi was down there so
terrible he was
he was what a what a shitty how terrible
is that man
well that's what happens you just start
shooting into a [ __ ] crowd
at 1 30 in the morning they hit 12
people one died
i think as of today two died [ __ ] sheesh
most victims are innocent bystanders
what about the dude with the airplane oh
be out yeah
b i'll tell you where you don't want to
go you know i'm like into all that
history [ __ ] we went to the
memorial of the oklahoma city bombing oh
yeah like you know i let like read these
books going into there because i was
like this would be cool to see not cool
to see dude
well it's not cool to see because what
they have is all the for all the people
that died in it
they have chairs for them and there's
little chairs for like the kids the kids
i didn't know it's for the kids so
there's you know there's the tour guide
hey man what's the little cheers for a
daycare he goes
oh because he blew up a daycare center i
was like i'm gonna leave now
thank you yeah it was it was pretty
heavy you have kids when you have kids
unimaginable right unreal that was the
daycare center yeah so timothy mcveigh
and his buddy
and his is his agenda was to blow up
government officials you know the feds
in the federal building
but they got warning that there's a
bombing so they decided to show up for
work that day
but they didn't tell the rest of the
building
it it's all strange how many how many
kids six
i think six or ten heartbroken you know
it ruined our day
yeah it was it was gonna go there and
you're like and it's like
some of the building like this is still
there one of the walls one of the walls
is
yeah this is weird [ __ ] like that like i
don't know if i ever told you my when i
lived on the walk streets in venice
i'm i'm just i loved it and i'm walking
down and they're
digging up like yeah and
what's going on you know well the guy
the guy who lived here before
killed his wife and buried her in the
front yard jesus christ and as they were
excavating they started
what's this this looks like a pelvis
jesus is crazy
oh [ __ ] damn yeah like the jfk one's
cool that oklahoma city bombing ones
that was pretty intense no dude don't
don't you walk right into it
it just feels heavy yeah yeah well i
want to get the [ __ ] out right away
i know jason you wanna go look over
there i'm like no i'm out of here
it was this is tough it's like possible
hey let's do a video for my brother it's
his birthday like here yeah here yeah
so he's like let's just do a real quick
roll happy birthday man everyone's all
sad
yeah i don't think i'm ever um anywhere
where it's really crowded
nowadays where i'm not looking for a
spring shooter
like just your comedy shows yeah but
that's a little bit different it's a
little bit targeted audience but i'm
talking about like when you go to
like if you're at an open area with all
different like there's a there's a
restaurant here restaurant here at those
open
malls everybody's kind of like oh yeah
yeah kids are playing
right dude i i was literally on the
goddamn ring for the logan paul fight i
looked around like there's so many
people here that's what i mean and
there's not a lot of security so i
told my guy what hey i'm gonna finish
the fight in the back he's like what we
got the best tickets in the house i'm
like
i know i have anxiety man i'm gonna
watch from back to a little much yeah
let's see if [ __ ] breaks off
if they start fighting or if there's a
shooter like i'm [ __ ] dude
he's like shooter like you never know
now you never know
you never know yeah it's intense i'd
like to think about
yeah i was telling my friend i go just
want a gun on me in case there's a
shooting and my buddy goes what do you
mean and i go
just if there's a spree shooter i want
to be able to shoot the guy before and
he goes
but what happens when the cops think
you're the shooter and they shoot you
yeah that'd be a problem
how about we get a notice on our phone
on saturday in oklahoma city they go
come to the airport early
security's heightened i'm like in
[ __ ] oklahoma city what are we doing
dude yeah well
some dumb dumb the plane was from la to
atlanta and they had to do a mercy stop
in
okc so in okc some guy
freaked out and tried taking the plane
over tried to open you know that
the door yeah tried opening that that's
a problem
oh what he got his ass oh he got his ass
everybody jumped on they gotta feed him
i live for those moments because i'd
like how much more time in the year an
hour
i'll take it from him
i'll take his [ __ ] his pants i say film
this got my piss on him afterwards
but uh yeah well you hope a guy like you
is on there because who was that guy who
played defensive end
in the nfl for a long time and kind of
just went crazy and tried to take the
door off and he's six foot seven
he's defensive end uh 280 pounds and
and was having a psychotic episode and
trying to pull the door
so so real quick but you had a quick
fact out there for the people
you know it's impossible to open that
door
yeah it's not the movies where it's like
open and the everybody gets sucked out
it's not it's not the movie i need like
2400 uh like i saw the same story you
need like
one i think they said 2400 uh pounds of
pressure to open that door
in the air they don't have that much
faith in humanity yeah that they're
going to
make it that easy to get in the door
yeah they know people are crazy the guy
who did that was a
was a former flight attendant too the
guy who was trying to open that door
probably not very good one because you
know how planes work you know right
wow none of nobody in here if all of a
sudden
guys got handcuffed he got no that was
another guy
that was another guy this guy and here's
the other thing because of september
11th remember
when the terrorists took over the
cockpit gun thing went just everybody
stay calm don't do anything
everyone's like okay we're gonna hear
them out now americans
if you try stealing the plane they get
they go oh we know how this ends and
they beat the [ __ ] out of you what
this guy got is united 93 the the shoe
bomber or the guy
yeah the shoe bomber yeah i tried like
he got his ass
the shoe bomber he tried letting the
bomb on shoot and then the the people on
the plane go oh
well you're isis yeah well we're we're
going to beat the [ __ ] out of you dude
hey everybody let's get him and they all
beat him towards an inch of his life
he's such a cuckoo bird
yeah he didn't he had a long history of
just being oh he did yeah
i love when americans get together and
beat the [ __ ] people well you gotta
you gotta do it and americans will do
that americans will beat the [ __ ] out of
you
so yeah that guy the the the um
that one the cockpit how about the one
flight attendant who kept harassing
a girl about her mask which is so
annoying and then she was like well i
don't want to wear a mask she's like
well you need to she went well cool
story
i'm gonna take my small little fist and
i'm gonna knock out your teeth now
i went knocked your teeth out wait no
the one who didn't want to wear a mask
yeah
was that the one where the the guy gets
in the way he goes don't you ever put
your hands on her is that what happened
i don't know
i think it is yeah i know it's running
because the other guy goes don't you
dare hit
she punched her in the face and knocked
her [ __ ] teeth knocked your teeth out
you're in so much trouble
in so many ways yeah probably not going
to fly for a while you're not going to
fly for a while but you're getting sued
there's all kinds of things
you knock somebody out nothing's i'm not
going to
rat the airline out but the the pilot
gets something is
i know it's confusing with the mass laws
you don't know where to put it on
where it uh you're supposed to wear it
this will be over soon hopefully for
everybody so
try to wear your mask yeah i assume i'm
like oh he's one of us
i just left my mouth down the entire
time no one said a word he
i had a guy no one said i had a great
this great guy who gets on and he goes
like this he goes
guys you i i know it's so annoying when
we say put your mask on
and it's like you're an adult you don't
want another adult ordering what you do
and we
get it but just know it comes from the
heart like we hate doing it but from our
heart
we're just trying to keep everybody safe
we don't really know how it works
either yeah we're just and everybody was
like [ __ ] no problem
it's just coming from the heart want to
watch it
yeah yeah i want to see it oh she got
all kind of they banned alcohol the
the planes are having a real problem
because people with the math stuff
they're really not having it dude
there's been teeth there's been more
assaults on uh flight attendants than
ever because well i mean well think
about it like when the especially these
people coming from cities where
the mass mandate they like they don't
have to wear a mask dude the mass
mandate's up tomorrow in l.a dude
i'm having a party is this by party i
mean
there's one but they're not showing the
video yeah she punched her right in the
[ __ ] grill
well that's not true yeah oh man
nothing's worse i wonder what happened
nothing's worse when you finally fall
asleep on the plane you just you're like
oh thank god
and your master feels a little bit like
sir
bro that happens to you so much on the
plane
because your [ __ ] just goes down yeah i
wear like that bag yeah
i've the same as the entire pandemic
yeah you fall loose it like falls down
and then you finally fall asleep i would
prefer they just take the mask and lift
up yeah let's just do that
just do that don't [ __ ] oh he's
coming to you like like your little baby
or something
oh
that guy came in way too late i know
right that was the ref for this
weekend's fight that's cool
go back to i didn't see the hit good for
that guy i love that guy no he's too
late though where were you when the
punch was well he played it
what's going on he probably didn't oh
there's a kid there oh no
gosh lady he was there pretty cool
he got there pretty quick yeah yeah the
lady in front of him too was kind of
holding trying to hold her back too
looked like
damn look at that she knocked your teeth
out oh
[ __ ] got her teeth knocked out poor
thing [ __ ]
[ __ ] that south yeah
she's doing her job that woman's a
[ __ ] oh she's yeah she won't be
flying for a while
oh my gosh everybody has a moment loses
their [ __ ] when you [ __ ]
punch she might have been studying with
wong
what if that lady went yeah
it's this part i have a problem with the
[ __ ] ah that's not
he said if you're really fighting
somebody i'm no problem with all of it i
have a problem there's no way anyone
would do this in a fight
if it was boxers would do it like boxers
would do it well he destroyed that box
the guys who actually fight the guys who
spend years in the ring like that you
you don't you think they would figure
out they'd go that
like front kick works yeah right or
roundhouse kick works
right or because those things have been
tried and true some of the other stuff
the spinning backfist sometimes works
elbows but this would have been this
would have
been if it would have found its way into
the game
with all never found its way into any
game even street fighting no one's doing
that that's right and even like this
like that you know that stuff that's
that's how that juice left that french
president
yeah you break your fingers when you do
that because sugar risks yeah
yeah yeah
let's take a little break from the
shenanigans because draft king
sportsbook is not only my favorite
sports book
but it's also america's top rated sports
book period
i love using draftkings sportsbook it's
easy to navigate plenty of instructions
for new bettors
nearly limitless ways to get in all the
action my friends and family have been
loving draftking sportsbook
and i know you guys are going to dig it
uh draftking sportsbook is putting you
courtside with a chance to turn one
dollar
into 100 in sight credits
that's right pick any basketball team in
this in
that is still in contention whether it's
the clippers the suns
the jazz who else you got you got
freaking
uh brooklyn you got milwaukee
all you gotta do is pick one of those
teams all right that's right pick
any team still in contention for the
title bet one dollar if that team wins
you win 100
in sight credits don't forget draftking
sportsbook also
offers great odds and promotions on
baseball hockey ufc
everything draftkings is safe secure
reliable so you can deposit and withdraw
your funds whenever you want
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook now and use the promo code
fighter when you sign up to turn one
dollar into 100
in free credits bet on the basketball
team of your choice to win their next
game
if they do you will claim 100 in free
credits that's promo code fighter
for limited time only at draftking
sportsbook must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only wager paid out in site
credits restricts and applies see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or an
indiana 109 with it who doesn't like
instant gratification if you're looking
for satisfaction there's no need to wait
with credit karma money
you could win cash reimbursements for
debit purchases
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases
you can buy stuff anyway why not get
reimbursed with some cash baby
when you use your credit karma money
debit card you can win daily instant
karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to five
thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card
and if you win you'll be notified on the
spot and your instant karma cash will be
added back to your spend account
credit karma money has already given
away over three million dollars in
instant karma and over 50
000 credit karma members and counting
open your fdic insured spend
account for free there's no minimum
balance requirements no
draft fees free withdrawals from a
network of over 50 000 atms
credit karma money progress starts here
right now visit creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning instant karma go to
creditkarma.com
win money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's credit
karma dot com slash win money
instant karma is sponsored by credit
karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and terms applies see rules
banking service provided by
mvb bank incorporated remember fdic
maximum balance and transfer limit
supply i'm i'm lamar odom you're [ __ ]
nick carter
you're aaron carter i kick your ass
did you did you buy that pay-per-view
which one the lamar odom
no i didn't
lamar odom versus aaron carter i didn't
was it did the fight happen
yeah it did happen anybody that bought
it i don't know
what the highlights i just saw this i
think you showed me on instagram yeah
how
why is lamar sagging watch this
and that's chuck liddell as a ref i'm
sorry but who i can't remember who aaron
carter is
his brother is the leader boys
he had the problem with the he has all
the problems yeah
name a problem he had a famous song in
the early 2000s
he was a kid star i don't want a thing
like it's something i want candy
yeah i that one yeah yeah that's um i
don't know how it went though the weight
classes are a little off and the whole
thing's a disaster
he's like videos he throws a party those
things are [ __ ] yeah
eric aaron's party or something like
that yeah he's such a small
guy on his face
i saw him training he just death
terrible you saw him trading we're on tv
uh no i'm not i know so i know the guy
who trained him like who like would box
with him he
like he would go to his gym the gym is
down in santa monica i'm not going to
put it on blast because i'm friends with
the guy but yeah
he looked terrible uh jim i delicious
not not that one not that one you're not
getting
yeah do you need cash that bad yeah
do you want to fight i lost chris you
would be there
fight christian no i'm not letting you
down no i won't do that i know how to
strike i would never bully you no but
it's like
too strong no and also i got the you
know
you know you know watch shinigami's
you know what it is it's different it's
different because if he gets mad and you
hit him he's going to he's going to
unload and it's just different you're
going to get caught
i don't know you're not going to hurt
him we'll see him
yeah i i uh every boxing coach i've ever
worked with said i hit way above my
weight class i'm sure that's amazing
i'm sure but you're also paying them but
yeah no no all three
never i want to say this though there's
no traitor there's no trainer
who doesn't say that just so you know
i've never worked with a guy who hits
mitch who didn't tell me
my hands were headed it's the hustle
here's the thing
i've done enough sparring with dudes who
are not that big but like
just a mexican guy who's been boxing for
a long time with a big head who comes in
and you're hitting him up and trying to
hit him and he's just kind of like yeah
taking it and it's just different you
know i
you guys don't need to do that i know we
would and i was just messing with you
i stick to kickball what's going on with
kate
i said i have a video of like my first
like boxing match i got my instagram
somewhere i'll
pull it up right now but you did a
boxing match yeah oh [ __ ] like a smoker
huh like a smoker i don't know what i
mean have you been boxing was it like an
amateur
it was amateur but like not like
sanctioned really did you have headgear
on
yeah you've been boxing a long time uh
since 2017 like is when i really got
into it
so how far down is the christian looks
like you're pretty athletic i played
hockey i played football i played
lacrosse i played everything
and i was just messing with you i'm not
trying to box you i was just talking
[ __ ]
uh keep going down yeah no it's just
let's go
it's a weight class thing that's awesome
yeah
i think you passed it right there next
to the right there yeah the shoe it's
like a short clip i'm the one in the
blue
it's like a short little clip this ko
that kid was 170 i was 130 at the time
this is the hey
[Laughter]
you're young why is it like this because
it wasn't my phone
oh [ __ ] it wasn't my camera they used
when they were filming bigfoot
oh my god like you can like no like
every every punch she like threw at me
every job i just
contested you ate this like no i
contested with my jab hand so he wasn't
connecting at all and then
who's the baddie in the neck yeah who's
that uh it's just uh
my friend i went to i like known for a
long time i went to high school the
second love of your life according to
you though yeah that was when i was
trying
you know oh you're trying to holler yeah
and y'all that's why you posted that
yeah of course come on
yeah i like your spirit christian and
then i have a picture with kylan
somewhere on here
well who's who's then who's that guy
who's the guy next to the hottie
clark duke oh yeah he's in a hot tub
time machine right yeah yeah
when i first now is this before after he
transitions what's going on there
brandon who me no yeah my hair wasn't
that great either but uh
yeah he shaves and he has rather soft he
has a soft chin that's all awesome you
don't need to be
yeah he's just that's just how he looks
right you would leave him
wait go back i do have a picture with
canon somewhere that i thought was kind
of funny uh it should be up
more right there oh [ __ ] there's you and
dalia at the store
yep boy do i look was it was that boxing
yeah that was the alzheimer's uh
day that oh that's right watson did yeah
i've done i've done his alzheimer's
thing
three years in a row and i've bought
i've bought um
you know sessions with trainers not and
not once have i used them
yeah i probably spent 600 in that place
all right chris you're welcome you can
fight man
i believe it this one isn't a great one
but
this is you posted it shark right yeah
this is like when i first got into
boxing the short guy's a good trader
yeah
dude he's in his name's also shark he
beat cancer he came back to like dude
that guy's
insane he's scared shark yeah what what
what ethnicity is he ukrainian makes
sense
is he was he a real boxer oh no he's a
sweater your gloves are green you look
like the guy from mike tyson
oh my god i got those because they look
like a special edition like where
do you know i'm talking about yeah i
know exactly what you're talking about
they uh had a certain uh sale going on
where a certain percentage of the
sales went to veterans so i was like
[ __ ] yeah
it was like the army green ones i was
like yeah no they look identical to the
mike tyson you look i don't know mike
tyson punch-out guy
i'll take it you know what i'm talking
about i'm not even clowning right now
this guy no no no little mac dude
come on chin there you go oh yeah
that's you dude damn no no hold on hold
on
i didn't say the cool smash brothers one
go to the 90s
the little mac guy now they got him on
[ __ ] roids look at his legs
there that's you
that's you there you are is that not
spot-on
spot-on i'll give you that one your your
ability to come up with
obscure character masks
is unmatched [ __ ] hilarious gianni
he said don't use the super smash bros
that guy sharks being in the show he's
like he beat cancer he's a good guy man
dude he he sharks a beast he had a heart
attack in the pool uh when he was
swimming in the ukraine he had like a
heart attack because he was a
like competitive yeah he was like i
think he was an olympic guy named shark
yeah and then like he had a heart attack
they brought him like they like
resuscitated him and then like he had
like
stage three i think some type of cancer
and he [ __ ] crushed it he was in the
gym every day
i was talking to him a little bit about
it when he had it i think when he had
just been diagnosed and so i'm really
glad
great he had like a great mentality he's
a tough kid man
dude he scares me good guy he scares me
he should he's from ukraine that's real
toughness that's grit
yeah [ __ ] yeah i got some issues with
your form we'll talk about it
well that was like i don't know why
china had to choose that one there were
more recent ones where my formula was
just showing me bro come on
appreciate that right little mac ryan's
gonna love him i gotta wear this he's
got some words about your
weight distribution all right what do
you got jen
okay so over the weekend somebody
decided to buy
a plane to write a message out into the
sky
and he basically proposed yeah he
proposed to his girlfriend and then he
proceeded to write uh
have the person write she said yes after
he proposed
and the last bit of his message is joe
roger
joe rogan is literally five foot three
you know that comes from right
when uh neil degrasse tyson was on
uh he goes joe like he was like all
things were relative he's like how tall
are your ninja goes
five eight i think he was are you do you
know that for sure he's like
have you actually had a proper
measurement just like i mean five eight
i guess
and that's where that comes from oh yeah
he's about five eight broken
oh yeah somebody decided to spend all
this guy just wanted to go viral that's
why i did it just to make the
proposal more viral i don't know if he
did it to go viral
17 g's to [ __ ] do that i saw that and
i was like somebody sent that to me
was that out here in california yeah
this shot is actually taken from rodeo
drive
our friend is so famous that famous
where people are spending seventeen
grand
dude when foucault calls you out you're
pretty famous
you're pretty famous when fauci the
white house has to address something you
said on your
podcast you're pretty famous i mean
famous famous yeah different level yeah
what else you got and this is a silly
tick tock where
somebody caught a girl at the very top
of a
uh parking structure which is across
from
a prison in i believe it was new york
she got out of her car and started
twerking for the prisoners and they
started to turn their lights on and off
the tombs this might be the tombs in
rikers island i think
oh that is yeah you're right that's
right yeah that's that's the tombs
though that's that's really good
um well first of all uh she's doing that
for her her man's in there
of course and god bless she didn't just
pull up her mans in that
oh is that what is that what they said
no that's what i'm saying oh
i've watched first four days way too
much that's the man's in there
and he's flashing the [ __ ] light and
then his other
crazy inmates like hell yeah dude
they're all jacking off to him now it's
in new york yes
yeah that's that's in new york new york
yeah that's also where uh
uh epstein was oh [ __ ]
yep wow there she is that's a hero right
there
i call her an american hero and i don't
care what anybody says the hero we don't
deserve
we call that community service oh
brennan someone just said what you said
she loves
she loves her man she's probably just
twerking for her man but the rest of the
jail
yeah the prisoner's natural complex
she has an ass on her too from this far
it's a bird's eye view but
i've ever filmed that film christian
sparring apparently
what else you got gin okay so over this
past weekend
the fights with the like the youtubers
and the tick talkers happened they had a
bunch of celebrities come out and
perform one of them being dj khaled
yeah and we're not really a performer is
he like he's a deep he's like a hype
he's
he doesn't sing so when he comes out i'd
be the same as i'm like all right i get
i mean
he's more of a producer than he is a
rapper or
another one yeah i think he's just i
think he's just a hype man when it comes
to but these young kids were not
they were not having it because they
were familiar with them and they
it was similar to the jaw rule
performance uh at that basketball game
where nobody
like was hyped about it nobody wanted to
see they're like responding
bro was struggling to get in the ring
they don't know the words no
[Applause]
the one where he's dancing walking on
the steps
how much did they pay him a good amount
they had
so it was a pretty penny what is he
doing here though what was he trying to
perform
he's a very famous producer please tell
me no one edited this
this was not edited so i've seen
multiple clips
it's a youtuber audience so they're
really young so like what
oh boy this one came out what 2008 yeah
like 2 000.
so it's cool but i mean i know the song
even i wouldn't
chime in yeah win win
everybody is going up yes i mean he came
in the back was like what
yeah there's no way anyone gave a [ __ ]
remember when he's trying to lose weight
and he's always on the stair master yeah
he's like this is what i do every day
and then just stay
just yeah looks like never lost rick
ross lost weight he did not he actually
lost weight
no gucci man gucci man lost a bunch of
weight but he loved him it's hard to do
you get it i don't know what have you
got jen
the foo fighters are having a concert
and they had they said that all the
audience members have to be vast to even
come in
and then i guess anti-vaxxers are upset
about this that are fans of their
theirs as well i mean if i love the band
so much i'll get vaccinated but they're
saying like sometimes some people have
you know health issues where they can't
get that vaccine for some reason
yeah whatever
given vaccines away we can't dish them
out enough
so yeah their fans are upset how about
that new flyers
long admire just held a concert for the
jabbed only the jabbed
look man i bet they don't give a [ __ ] i
mean i understand the i understand the
principle of
i'll never buy them existing the coved
vaccine because of how it was handled
but
vaccines saved lives
hey scroll up well do you see what
happened to that uh european soccer
player
got a second vaccination ran on the
field had a heart attack yeah
the healthiest guy in the world there
are people that have very bad reactions
to vaccines there's no doubt but
overall you have to decide but how many
of those do you like smallpox
more than vaccines do you like polio
more than vaccines would you like
coven more yeah my thing is if i was
a big fan of you know like you gotta get
back like if the store
the store did i mean for a long time
like came in to be on stage you got
vaccinated it's like crying
i get it i get why people are pissed off
though it's like
you know you let's be honest you're not
gonna be i said this from day one you're
not gonna be able to do [ __ ] including
getting in a plane on a plane without a
vaccine passport
i'm saying but this is what happens
though you gotta go jin let me see what
that guy said yeah
up one more so i get it because not all
people that choose to not vaccinate are
conspiracy there's some people very
close to me have autoimmune conditions
that make the vaccine high risk yeah
my thing is this if you if you're in a
high-risk category 21's white zone
that's just what
if you're if you're in a really vaccine
category you you might want to if you're
in a high-risk category for covid
i can see the i i would get a vaccine
that makes sense
i mean i'm vaccinated but what's
frustrating me if
if they want more people to get vaccines
it's like well now i mean tomorrow the
mass go away so that's fine but
to me it's like i'm vaccinating get i
still have to wear it on the plane
i thought the air this was the same well
this is what drives me [ __ ] nuts
about it and then disneyland goes yeah
you guys can come back we have to wear a
mask like
yeah but if we're vaccinating we have to
work with you vaccinating
you have two masks on well he doesn't
count yeah but
but there's no one there's been no rhyme
or reason man
i just haven't vouched in the email said
mass don't work and that we still do it
he said it not just email he said it
persons yeah
and then said he lied so that's good
government official yeah what else you
got jen
this is from the mediator instagram
handle and this guy does taxidermy
and he made a pillow out of a coyote
show me a coyote pillow
so it's a soft mount that's disgusting
oh my god it looks so real too is his
head soft size
no no i think it's just the body see do
you want to touch its nose brendan
so it looks like it's looking up that
thing would scare the yeah if you put on
your face
on the head that's great work though
it's great work
some guy said i need a guy to do my dog
like that
dude that looks incredible i know right
dude that's
disgusting i know it is disgusting
though it's disgusting but i kind of
want to lie on it oh no
hard pass really yeah hard pass
something yeah
do you think if you do that like a
big-ass line or something just somebody
watching your house like what
that's that'd be fun that looks real as
awkward i know the real wolf what is
your coyote coyote
that's a real one i don't want that
small-ass coyote give me a [ __ ]
thick-ass wall i'm sure he could do it
they are the most adaptable
creatures on the planet fruit
they'll eat anything yeah coyotes yeah
they are the ones
um they can adapt to any environment the
super cold
the the very hot arizona that's why
there's so many of them they're all over
the hills and they'll eat they'll eat
the fruit that falls from trees they'll
eat whatever yeah they're pieces of [ __ ]
hey you know uh when they when you hear
them howl at night they're doing a
call they're taking account of how many
people are around
really when they're like all howling
they're making sure they're uh they're
counting how many are around they ate a
lot of cats
oh yeah a lot of cats i don't mind i
don't like cats but they ate a lot of
stuff
whatever they'll be small dogs too oh
yeah watch out for your kids too they'll
[ __ ] your
small child small kids rarely you can't
hear that [ __ ]
at night the coyotes yeah when they when
they kiss i've been hurting for a while
around my i used to hear them all the
time and then they just kind of do you
know that baby deer
like little fawn they can't walk and
they just they lie there in the grass
do you know how do you know why they
don't get killed by coyotes that eat the
[ __ ] out of them bears everybody eats
them
but do you know why they don't they you
know what their defense mechanism is
it's kind of crazy
yeah baby deer slime all over no
but no like why why why don't they get
found you'd think if you had a little
baby deer there everything wants to eat
it right it's just in the grass it's
fawning it's right there
so what is it well guy drops out of
college though dude they don't give off
any scent
they don't give off a scent and then the
mother lapse up the poo
and the urine i guess probably the
distance yeah
just to clean it up so yeah so that so
that
you know bears and [ __ ] don't eat them
that's crazy how does it not give off
any scent it's so weird it's nature
protecting them yeah
sitting in it and my buddy was driving
this tractor
ran over the things hoof things like
beep beep
he had to pick it up he's like oh i'm
sorry did you kill it no he [ __ ] it
kind of was like all wobbly and stuff
then he put it back in
he definitely died paul was okay hoof
was okay and the mom
he said you know if you touch it the mom
will will reject it not true
mom came back and fed him and he was
fine
right here yeah he had a little spot
wait so he popped the hoof
back in he just ran over the hoof and
that thing was but it didn't break ran
over a lawnmower and he was like
no it was just no what a tractor and
they was like oh they didn't break it
i don't know are you protecting your
friend right now yeah but this is what i
think happened
your friend ran over his hoof the thing
clearly is
compromised he was like oh [ __ ] dude
he's like put it back down
and then the coyotes went well that's a
crying baby dare we're gonna eat him ass
first in front of you dude and then the
mom's gonna be like no not my baby i'm
gonna kill her
that's what you do that's what happened
well what i would do is i'd go
i'd go i mean i love venison and i'd go
well
things hoof is all kinds of jacked up
bears eat
these guys coyotes eat these guys
bobcats eat these guys
i'm part of the animal kingdom still i
would put him out as misery i would take
him by his little
nose just like that yep
yep you got that kind of strength to
kill a baby there
with one hoof yes he does i think we all
do oh okay
they're so fragile do you see the video
of the oh you're right now
or the leopard there was like a baby
gazelle laying down
and the cheetah came up went like or
line whatever the [ __ ] it was came up
behind it
and like oh it played dead no no it
killed it like it killed the baby
oh gazelle it was just i thought you had
it i thought you had a different story
no i know it like you talk about just
the circle of life well
i thought it was like a cool thing to
like to see but i watch these videos
every day
just like sitting there no i saw one
derrick gazelle in africa
a lot the lines were circling or
whatever they're like attacking one and
then the other one was going away
and they just played dead which i
thought he was getting eaten face first
but they were
they just really gone yeah he played
possum then popped up and ran off
they've had weird cases and it's look
deception where
the elk will be they'll be running or a
moose and the wolf pack will
get it and it's a long chase and the
what would the alcohol sit there in the
snow and it can't move
it's done and the wolves are sitting
there staring at it and they stare at
each other
and for whatever reason all the wolves
turn around and walk away
it's this death stare and then they
decide because they know he's gonna
sometimes they decide not to eat the
[ __ ] animal i really i read that in
of wolves
they just wanted to kill the damn thing
they don't know what it is they just
think that it's
a respect thing yeah um maybe they're
like good fight doug
how would you google that exactly i
don't know how big do those [ __ ]
wolves get i put
wolves get big yeah this might be a
story that i read in a book
that's not true that never happens you
know what i mean
like this might be i remember reading it
going what the [ __ ]
was that story yeah yeah you're in a
children's club
because in the real life those wolves
gather around that uh and they don't
ask first rip his nuts off
couldn't find it it's called the death
stare the death star yeah
you know it ain't real no it might be
yeah we'll look for it later
other things
uh tell me if i brought this up already
but remember brian saying uh that guy
that
grabs people's nuts that's his power
move in wrestling did we watch at it or
no no
we tried to find her right okay it was a
while ago right
this guy's yeah we could never find the
video though so i guess his name is joey
ryan joey ryan
his moves the dick grab yeah so joy
ryan's the guy i think on the he's like
chris paul
very few will get that reference
so wait a guy on the bottom actually
this is not going to work super
homologous
he's all yeah
what a weird job oh shoot he's not even
grabbing it there
[Applause]
god is that my dad as a pro wrestler
my dad looks just like that oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] there's a new guy in town
come on dude from eli drake
dude how embarrassing but that's
basically his move the guy with the
mustache is joy ryan
and that's his name that's his move they
probably get paid a lot of money he's
through tw
twitch i don't know no oh i'm trying to
help him out i was trying to help him
like it's kind of dumb that people are
complaining about this but did you guys
hear that people are
complaining about uh at assigner for
grabbing vitoria's ass in the middle of
the fight they're like saying that
oh like i can't believe that they're all
okay and like we're laughing that he
basically sexually assaulted us
holy [ __ ] this is not that new but it's
not a complex and that was cool
yeah some business guy white dude
oh [ __ ] chappelle's polar opposition
that mario
back to you this is the real white mike
[Music]
that was it yeah that was cool america
that's america right there guys
it makes me feel good
yeah i was watching my cyrus sing
do covers of various songs oh you're
super born
let me rock climbing my side spirits
cool dude
yeah rock climbing cover cool dude busy
week
took a bunch of herbs from my cold he
had a busy weekend
that's the last one so there's an nbc
slip and slideshow
and i guess it had to be postponed
indefinitely because there was like a
explosive diarrhea outbreak
between multiple people misspelled there
correct i know yeah it is or maybe
that's some different ways
diarrhea right do they have video of
this uh
no no no they don't have the video of
the outbreak they don't but uh you know
rob funches i guess he's supposed to be
one of the hosts for this show too
roger sorry ron punches um
but apparently the water they're using
on the show somehow it's not that clean
so somehow
oh the people have been effective
mexican what are you talking about
giardia is a [ __ ] what is it
giardia
what is that that from bad water so if
it just gets into your mouth or if you
touch it oh dude oh
everyone got diarrhea was going down the
slide
that's what that's how they make you
want to always call slippers 40 crew
members caught the infection
that [ __ ] hits your eyes yeah so if you
touch it it's a wrap dude clean water is
the the fact that we figured out how the
way to get parasites that are out of
water is one of the biggest advances in
in health care in history
like you can't [ __ ] drink just
regular water
now did um is it what was the water in
mexico you were talking was it in mexico
anywhere in most of the world where you
and you [ __ ] with the ice or whatever
you're going to get an amoeba
a giardia parasite whatever you get
parasites
yeah and they work their way through
your body yeah people like margaritas
right quick toot sweet broth those are
diarrhea slushies dog
yeah and people you'll be throwing up
and you'll be it'll be a problem for you
yeah tequila get rid of that um
yeah maybe sometimes diarrhea is fine
sometimes you need a little diarrhea man
just let it all out yeah it helps
sometimes yes it sounds fun
yeah a little rusty when you have a
colonoscopy they make you take this
this stuff and it makes your diarrhea
out yeah and then they stick a camera in
your
isn't that a certain age you got to get
those yeah at 50. and then another
five years and then another five years
oh you got to get them all the time
what'd they say about your shooter clean
as a whistle
clean daddy's clean as a whistle he's
got good genetics what they say about
that old peach
prostate flat as a pancake that's not
good right
no it's very good you want it flat flat
flat that's where they put the
the finger they don't do that anymore
now you can do it with like a blood test
i had a doctor dude
he put that thing in you made no sense
i was there and i was supposed to get a
check up for fighting and he put his big
sausage finger in my ass that's a
[ __ ] they put they take ky and
they put it all the way up in there huh
i hate her and then i asked him if
anybody else got it done they went nope
well that's sexual harassment i'm
thinking about suing
you've had no you had them stick it up
here they do that when you started
getting to be around
40 i'm 34. yeah you have some time you
might as well
do it though yeah you know
you're [ __ ] into it yeah
blood test and stuff yes they got a
blood test i'll do the blood test for it
you think it came with a blood test for
a long time
i know it's a finger you babies yeah oh
no no
whatever it's not just if you've never
done
yeah and here's the problem yeah you
can't clinch i i don't know why i did
this but i think he did
he's just there
like right away your instinct when it
gets to you you clinch all right so
they're like you got to relax
you have to try to imagine relaxing as
he's putting and it's a he
putting his finger all the way through
your butt that's never a hot chick no
it's like some hair and what they
probably
i got it years ago yeah just to test
something in my stomach
area yeah i saw you i should get it
uh for the prostate thing for sure yeah
yeah okay when you're
50 dude well when did you start testing
40s
50 50. well i think colon cancer
prostate like
40. yeah colon cancer kind of stuff they
test earlier i was in my late 30s
the drink they make you take like makes
you [ __ ] everywhere right yeah
because i know my my my dad had a
colonoscopy
took the drink where he's it's supposed
to clean out his colon yeah
didn't realize that like he wasn't
supposed to eat after a certain time
eight went to the colonoscopy like ah
nah you you ate too late like you got to
do it again so we had to do the whole
process all over again
yeah so i feel like you gotta be clean
they knock you under for a colonoscopy
yeah just take a
camera all the way up your ass and then
you wake up you like so so colon cancer
and if you can take care of your
cardiovascular branch
and your colon you have a much higher
chance of living a lot longer most
people die from some kind of heart
disease and i guess colon cancer is the
number one and colin you don't know just
too late
yeah it's hard to detect yeah pancreatic
cancer too you have no nervousness
so you just don't know by the time it's
spread you're [ __ ] the old ticker
so and the ticker calcium and plaque
buildup and stuff
it's all that weird stuff is that it
changes that's talking about the
ding-a-ling
no man you're hard bro oh damn it
you're calling it i was like just
calling what it
listen listen up albany come see me this
week
friday saturday i'm excited funny about
i can't wait oh wait we have uh we have
graphics for you guys hold on one second
oh good and then i got
uh and then i got uh my one of my
favorite clubs of all time
helium comic club philadelphia is that
funny
i hope so buddy the healing helium june
25 26 27 that's a sunday i'm doing i
can't believe that
but i can't wait helium comedy club big
news
i am doing roughhouse fridays starting
the poirier conor mcgregor fight where
i'm gonna um basically
have i'm gonna create odds for mma
betting talk about finding my favorite
thing
you're gonna create odds for it yeah
well i'm gonna have experts on and i've
got some great
new shop yeah it's called roughhouse
fridays nice tom mccormick
um and uh it's gonna be a lot of fun so
i'll keep you guys posted people
see these dates well if they're
listening they can't see it uh
pittsburgh i'm off for a while
pittsburgh is july
22nd through 24th august north carolina
19th through the 21st of august
september we got a bunch of dates but
right now we just have denver
comedy works downtown denver september
30 through
october 2nd and hold up chapel oh
i got it i got ready i got a little bit
of a break too july 15th
through the 17th i'll be nice huh yeah
nice to have a little break timonium
maryland magooby's joke house
and then i'm excited for brea california
august 26th just a one-nighter
boom maybe i'll come with you to that
obviously
hey you ain't got to poke me like that
slow down on the poke
slow down in the poke yeah you can do
that to him all day that's your thing
i was like damn damn chappelle's been
feisty today feisty
let's fight you i'll take care of
you oh my god you got some words about
your form now
yeah i don't know you don't want to box
me bubba anyways but we can if you want
i don't want to watch you guys
can you do it and not show him i'll box
me all right we'll box i'm done i'm
going to
tell you about boxing don't tell me i'll
do some light sparring how much you
weigh
enough to hit your heart
my older brother and we hit hard he's
200 pounds so i think i'll be able to
he's in his 20s just watch chris i was
joking when i said that
now you got a new battle that man right
there
i'm watching you spar it's good it's
awesome i've watched both of you spartan
i don't see anything
okay all right that's it all right see
you
let's do it